to be clear you
are not going forward with this
i'm gonna fix it myself
hey guys pete here today i'm going to be
talking about better call saul season
six the final season and it's finally
coming we have double release dates
since this longer 13 episode season is
getting broken up into two parts we have
some short teasers some promotional
photos and the creators and actors have
all said some interesting things about
the final season that are worth
revisiting while we wait to get a proper
season six trailer
to get all the basic info out of the way
better call saul season 6 is supersized
at 13 episodes rather than the standard
10. this is likely to help conclude both
the jimmy mcgill and gene timelines saw
goodman's story before and after he
became walter white's lawyer and
breaking bad it wouldn't be a huge
surprise if we get some teasers or
scenes in the original show's timeline
as we did in episode 5 of season 4. but
just keep in mind that the finale of
better call saul season 5 happened in
june of 2004 the first episode of
breaking bad took place in september of
2008 so there is still a large gap of
time between the two series personally i
don't think we'll see multiple time
jumps to close the gap completely where
they are right now there's plenty to
wrap up just with jimmy's story but you
never know i feel like what needs to
happen is that who saul is when we first
meet him needs to make sense in relation
to the person we've been watching for
the last five seasons i don't believe
they need to fill in every blank along
the way for the release date this is
also super sized in that we have two of
them as mentioned the final season will
be broken up into two halves the first
two episodes of the first half will
premiere on april 18th then you'll get
weekly releases to follow that through
episode 7 which will bring back the
concept of the mid-season finale
although i think it's worth mentioning
that it doesn't sound like they went
into the writing process with this in
mind back when all amc shows split their
seasons they wrote them to have an
actual finale halfway through it was
more like breaking it into two seasons
and this might not be the case with
season six either way the second part of
the season will premiere on july 11th so
there's only a seven week gap in between
that means that the better call saul
series finale will air on august 15th
they had some fun hinting at the release
date in the first two teasers they
released they used the tagline mark your
calendars without directly announcing
what the date was in the first teaser we
see the cousins leonel and marco
salamanca arriving at the crime scene
outside of lalo's hacienda in mexico
this is no doubt related to gus's failed
attempt on his life in the season 5
finale you can see the mexican federal
police on hand and the creators used the
evidence markers with the letters d and
r as clues that's the 4th and 18th
letters in the alphabet for the 4 18
release date in the second teaser you
see gustavo fring entering his home
after collecting his mail and the
address above the door is also 418.
there's not much useful information for
speculation in either of these to
discuss it does seem a little strange
that there would be an official
investigation into what happened at
lalo's place but you can see that the
police officers at the scene are very
respectful towards the cousins they
overlook the fact that they kick the
evidence marker and even sort of bow
their heads not to make direct eye
contact when they pass by in the gust
teaser he's wearing the clothing we're
used to seeing him in at los pollos
harmanos but that isn't anything out of
the ordinary for the most part these
both seem to be about teasing the date
which did make for a fun few minutes of
speculating until someone or more likely
multiple people online put it together
and posted about it
there was also an amc ad that aired
during the super bowl that had a couple
of short sequences from season six and
the first one did have a breaking bad
character cameo in that jimmy comes into
the nail salon where he finds a lot of
potential new clients waiting for him
and on the right side of the screen you
can see spooge behind the fish tank
you'll remember him getting his head
crushed by an atm machine he stole and
saul did mention that he was his client
in the original series when that came up
while he was talking to walt there's
also a quick shot of gus meeting with
someone at the chicken farm and a shot
at kim looking over her shoulder a lot
of people brought up the shirt she's
wearing and how it doesn't really look
like her normal style it has a floral
print and so that led to some wild
speculation that she's maybe involved in
something happening in mexico i mean it
does look more like something lala would
wear than what she would but that's also
a pretty big stretch the final teaser
where they actually confirmed the
release date is the most interesting one
but this is where we have to consider is
this purely promotional or is this
teasing something that will actually
happen in one of the episodes
historically better call saul does
usually put out a number of preseason
teasers with content that they produce
separately to promote the show the
reason i bring that up is that this
third teaser appears to show gene
returning to albuquerque it's in black
and white just like everything jean's in
and starts with a close-up shot of jimmy
that you see is on a wanted poster when
the camera pulls back it's offering a 5
million dollar reward for information
leading to the arrest of james m mcgill
aka saul goodman and has a phone number
plus the email address saul tips dea
info.org from the other flyers on the
board it's clear that this is hanging
somewhere in albuquerque and just in
case you forgot gene works in omaha
nebraska but you do see him walk by and
pull it down as he passes gene returning
to new mexico would be a very big deal
if it actually happens so i guess we're
gonna have to wait and see if this is
something that's gonna show up the email
address is fake but if you call the
number on the flyer you do hear this the
number you have reached is no longer in
service there is no further information
at this time that is definitely a
recording of bob odenkirk's voice and
that led some fans to speculate that the
poster in number was something that gene
made himself as a part of a scheme i can
see where they're coming from the five
million dollar reward seems rather high
and jimmy is a schemer plus we are
expecting that there will be some sort
of face-off with jeff the taxi driver
now that he's identified him but this
shot being in albuquerque kind of feels
disconnected from that it makes for a
good tease though and i'm excited to see
if there's more to it after all one
thing we know for sure is that we will
be getting an ending for gene's story
there has been several mentions of that
in interviews the showrunner peter
goulds is the most repeated he told ew
anyone who watches the show carefully
and is thinking about where this is all
going one of the questions you have to
ask yourself is what does this man
deserve not just what's going to happen
to him but what would be a deserving end
to this does jimmy mcgill saul goodman
gene takovic deserve death does he
deserve love what would be the most
fitting end for this guy for the show
obviously the end for everybody is death
but that may not be where we leave this
guy is there any way for him to win any
redemption after everything that he's
done when tv guide asked his co-creator
about gene's fate vince gilligan said i
love the story of someone who has done a
lot of bad things nonetheless redeeming
themselves and in a recent article from
the new york times they visited the
final season set to interview bob
odenkirk and the scene they were
shooting certainly sounded like one of
jean's vince gilligan was also directing
that one and we know he's directing the
penultimate episode 6-12 so that might
also confirm that there will be more
gene content and maybe even whole
episodes in his timeline to end the
series ever since it was announced there
were going to be 13 episodes people
started to wonder will we get like three
whole gene episodes at the end so this
might be kind of pointing in that
direction it is pretty funny when you
think about how little time has passed
in those omaha scenes and then just how
long it's taken for them to come out
peter gold has said that they all might
take place over just a few days or weeks
and they've been shooting them for
almost six years in that new york times
article there is a mention of the finale
script the interviewer is there when ray
seahorn learns that bob got to read it
and asked him what he thought he tells
her i think i like it but i was pretty
wiped out when i read it in the middle
of the night i think it's a challenging
way to go to finish the series it's not
flashy it's substantial and on some
level it's things i hoped for for years
in this character's brain on the other
hand yeah i have to read it again but
what i like about it is it's not cheap
it's not easy it doesn't feel cartoonish
it's pretty great i think it's pretty
great he added i would want to end on
this kind of character development focus
that's what it's about instead of
something that just has guns in it i
guess there's a few guns but they're not
like in other episodes and he tells the
reporter i spend a fair amount of time
doing crimes this season just stupid
crime so this seems like a good place to
wrap things up we've got less than two
months to go before the final season is
here i'll be covering the whole thing
and putting out more bcs videos between
now and then let me know in the comments
what you think about the teasers and all
your thoughts about the final season
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon